duras madame monsieur bonsoir nous en
avons parlé hier la radio vision est
donc né à rouen en deux mots de ce
système français permet de capter sur
votre minitel un texte qui s'inscrit en
illustration de votre programme radio
l'inventeur s'appelle dimitri baranov
fils a été financé par l'agencé
nationale pour la valorisation de la
recherche en haute normandie
plus de détails avec pierre duval
regardons bien cette image c'est une
exclusivité ce boîtier blanc de haute
technologie est un radio décodeur grâce
à lui on assure une liaison entre un
minitel et un transistor
c'est de la radio vision on savait déjà
écouter la différence entre les oreilles
on peut maintenant l'entendre avec ses
yeux pour la première fois en france une
radio privée
hervé ès arts on transmet de
l'information sur un minitel par
l'intermédiaire d'un radio décodeur un
radio décodeur inventé par un ingénieur
conseil français est prouvé il ya déjà
pas mal de temps
l'astuce qui consiste à mélanger de la
musique de petites informations
électroniques que l'on n'entend pas qui
n'altère absolument pas la qualité
musicale
ce décodeur ce radio décodeur fait donc
le tri entre ces différentes
informations entre la musique et ses
petites informations électroniques et
affiche cédé hier sur l'écran du
militaire le nouveau système médiatique
enrichit les informations que le rythme
de la radio en empêche
c'est exact la radio reçoit
quotidiennement beaucoup d'informations
qu'elle ne peut pas passer à l'antenne
pour ne pas casser le rythme musical
comme on dit et ce système permettra
donc de passer par exemple des résumés
de là
thual it et des résultats sportifs les
résultats du loto par exemple et un tas
d'informations intéressant la région à
partir d'une banque de données reliées
au minitel l'ordinateur de la station
émettrice sélectionne les informations à
transmettre par ce mélange heures qui
écrèment les informations choisies par
l'auditeur est simple aimeront
simultanément sur son minitel le radio
déconneur permettent ainsi de capter un
texte qui s'inscrit en illustration du
programme de la station décrit comme par
exemple une traduction ne prosor du coup
oui mais super pas
alors le prochain radioclit cessera matt
bianco au monde et la can be dans une
dizaine de minutes environ
80 auditeurs test de rbs ont été dotés
d'un radio décodeur pour l'instant ils
peuvent accéder à deux programmes
indépendants du sont diffusées par la
station l'horoscope cours de la bourse
pages de publicité télématique et
parallèlement les radios cris
l'étagé d'une manière merveilleuse une
manière dont on attendait même pas du
tout les résultats de cette façon on a
engagé une sorte de vide parade sur
lequel on demandait aux auditeurs de
réagir par le biais du minitel on leur a
demandé de voter par ml minitel où
attendait 10 % de réponses ont eu 50 %
de réponses c'est à dire 40 réponse sur
une 80 des décodeurs déposé
encourageante l'expérience devrait
permettre la commercialisation des
décodeurs de radio vision dans le
courant 86 pourtant ce système soulève
la comparaison avec celui d' antiope
presque une objection
effectivement ce système existe déjà
mais à l'échelon national
par contre ce système intéressera
beaucoup les auditeurs des radios
locales privées qui par définition sont
régionales derrière ce décodeur se
décide
une ambition de communiquer autrement
avec une population locale
départementale ou régionale
il est vrai que nous sommes à l'heure de
la décentralisation la direction
générale des télécommunications prévoit
6 millions deux minutes elle dans les
ménages d'ici les trois ou quatre années
à venir
dans la